from espn get up and so much more our
friend dan orlovsky back here on the
program how are you dan
what's going on boss man i'm doing
absolutely fantastic how are you doing
i'm doing fine did i see in the
commercial break you and damian woody
tweeting about being on a peloton bike
did i see that damn
i just i just got off the iron horse it
was a really impressive performance if i
may so much
to myself very good uh i saw what he
wants to get on so i'd love to kick his
teeth in on that too
okay so uh are you are you putting on
your peloton profile all the other
uh organizations that you might want to
uh broadcast for outside of espn or
that's just somebody else that's fake
yeah that would go over really well with
jimmy piccardo would be my guest
yeah yeah well you you would be kj
orlovsky
right that's the way it would be yeah
all right my agent my agent david cooney
and matt olson at caa would be on me in
10 seconds delete that delete that
delete that take that down
oh my gosh well let's let's let's talk
about i guess the here and now uh dan
orlovsky
because i was feeling a little bit of
heat
uh the other day and i was wondering is
it just hotter outside
or is that dan orlowski's take that the
seahawks should fire pete carroll if he
stands in
uh russ wilson's way could that have
been it dan
did that the other day no no that that
was a that was an accurate feeling of
mine
um here's here's why i stand on the
russell what's the situation okay
it's one of two things i don't think
this is football related i don't think
russell's that bent out of shape of his
offensive line or
whatnot i think this is either that he's
unhappy playing with a defensive minded
coach that you know halfway through the
season or 10 games
through the season last year decided
okay we got to run the ball a little bit
more
and you know russ throwing around a lot
is slowing down for us a little bit he's
unhappy doing that and it's about that
relationship
or this is about 20 years from now
russell wilson
and russell's brand and legacy and
trying to become the nfl's magic johnson
so to speak when it comes to ex-player
businessman and the seattle sea i've got
to figure out which one it is because if
it's about
russell wilson's brand 20 years from now
his mind is already made up
it's done no one more year in seattle is
not going to change that so
i would say in that moment you got to
figure out a way to move them now
because this star is the brightest get
as much as you can from them from a
desperate organization
if it's about pete if russell's like not
i've no desire to leave seattle i want
to play here forever
and this is about being unhappy with the
style of the organization of the brand
of football
then you gotta sit there and go well is
it replay repairable between
that those two guys that if it's not are
you gonna give up russell wilson to keep
peter
i would not okay
so uh let's parse this a little bit
um because you're also perfect to ask
about this
uh former quarterback who also is
outstanding at
watching tape and communicating about it
russ
the 397 sacks all the offensive line or
is russ not thrown on time or what would
pete carroll say about all those sacks
that uh have been suffered by the
quarterback and
and whether it's the system or the uh
offensive line or
or a team effort if you will yeah on
that front yes
some of them are on russell there's no
question about it um
60 40 offensive line to russell you know
obviously
it takes everybody receivers wrong route
you know poor
communication all that stuff but i've
heard that get said over the past couple
weeks that russell
owns some of them um because of his
style of football
and i've kept my mouth quiet on it
because
i feel like in when people say that i go
well no no duh
but that's why he's russell wilson if
everybody wants him to play this
efficient brand of football and get it
out on time or something like that
he's not going to be who he has over the
last nine years
like it's a give or take if you want the
special russell
if you want the great russell if you
want the guy that over the last decade
has been one of the five best
quarterbacks in football
it you're gonna have to take some of
that stuff that should he he can't
become special he can't be special
without
some of the negative aspect of it and
that's just the style of football he
plays
so to say well russell shouldn't hold on
to the ball that long well then you're
gonna get a four yard completion
and anybody can do that so again i
i just don't know i i i i i think
what you just you know your your your
first answer
where you if it is about russell down
the road and setting himself up for down
the road
um i agree with you his mind will have
to be made up
and then you have to figure out how you
get something for him
the thing is with pete carroll he's
turning 70 this fall i can't imagine
he'd
he'd he'd um throw his hands up right
and say well that's the end of that um i
i can't imagine
that this this relationship is going to
end in divorce
um this summer i just don't i don't feel
it i don't have that spidey sense
dan and i i and pete's smart enough to
also know
um you know how to how to navigate this
although that athletic story the thing
that that left out at me
was yeah that there could absolutely be
a moment in time on planet earth where
with all due respect to brought brian
schottenheimer he feels that he's got
the ability to tell russell forget it
get out of the room or
say something make him storm out of it
there's just a lot of confusion for me
here
to be honest yeah i think there's i
think there's three parts to that for me
okay um number one it begins with
what could you get for him you know i
think that that's a fair question to ask
if the chicago bears who need a absolute
dude at the position are gonna throw you
three or four first rounders
then it becomes a very real
consideration as great as russell is
i think the second thing is what is
their opinion
on somebody in the draft they may love a
guy like trey land
right they may love him and go well we
love trey lance
we think he's gonna fall somewhere
between 10 and 15
if we get three or four first round
picks maybe we could package them to go
get go up and get trey lance
and the third thing would be this and
i've said this a couple times now pete
and john schneider have
two experiences in their time together
in seattle
one early on when russia was cheap and
everyone around him was really good and
well paid
and they won the super bowl and then one
when they decided to pay russell as they
should have
top dollar because he earned it he's
that good and they've struggled to
replicate that success
they may sit back and go you know what
we tried it the other way
we tried to do it that way it is really
really really hard and we have one of
the best guys
let's go back to the other way and i
think those are all layers
that are part of this conversation for
seattle
dan orlowski here on the rich eisen show
so what is the answer
uh with them staying together if you you
know you
dan orlowski consultant could be hired
by seattle
but what is the offensive mix here
because you've got it to me dk metcalf
has
the ability to wind up number one in the
entire nfl
like he he we just saw that leap forward
and lockett is phenomenal
and they do have a running game that
they that they wisely employ
you know from time to time what what is
the answer to let russ
cook i mean what we got here dan because
i don't think this is going to be
a divorce i just don't i don't feel it
yeah so
it starts with seth walder their their
new offensive coordinator
um um shane walder waldron excuse me
shane so i was with shane waldron
uh three years ago in la when he was
really our tight end coach
with the rams and you could see super
very much so observant you know
really paying attention to sean and matt
those conversations what not so it
starts with him what's his philosophy
what's his belief with
how to take russell to the next step so
to speak when it comes to
taking less hits being less on the run
and now i think it's looking at all of
russell's plays
and going okay the the
80 of the plays that we have russell
that you play with in the structure of
the offense and and the structure of the
offense sometimes gets dumbed down
for people just because we say structure
of the offense doesn't mean it's
dink and dunk doesn't mean it's this
boring
um elementary passing game it just means
within the structure of
everybody tied together hey this is a
shot play where we're going to roll you
out and set you up
in between the middle of the field on
the hash 14 yards deep and we're going
to try to push the ball 60 yards
downfield
if it's not there you're going to find
two to three to a check down or an
outlet that it's still within structural
play so 80
of those plays russell do we believe
that we can play
top three positional football and do
that yes all right so then let's look at
the other 20
why do they happen is it because our
offensive line is terrible
we're asking them too much in their past
protection schemes
are you bad at communicating at the line
of scrimmage do you try to do too much
is it situational football when it's a
one score all those things
get tied into trying to figure out
because richard really comes down to
three to five plays a game three to five
plays a game where if you go
you get rid of that ball a second sooner
or we gotta build in a hot route for you
a little bit more
or you know what our our center can't do
this we got to stop asking to do that
that is all entailing of trying to
figure out how to get him
happier quote-unquote on the football
field and i think
we boiled it down to the to the uh to
the crux of the matter dan it seems like
those three to five plays is
where russ and pete have a different of
a difference of opinion
on what to do in those three to five
plays right where
and if those three to five plays that
are a difference of opinion and russ
does what he wants to do and turns the
ball over that's when pete's like screw
it
that's it yeah i mean we're we're going
to tap out here on
on all that business and we're going to
get back to basics and we're going to
try and win football games that way
that's and that's it the last thing i
would throw into that rich is this
that is not just an offensive identity
you can't do like i i said this about
when cam went to new england this past
year with josh mcdaniels
yes you want to do those things as an
offense
and that might help you play better or
more efficient or
error error free on offense but does it
play
winning football you know like winning
football
is connected to what your defense is
sometimes your defense isn't good enough
so you can't do that as a quarterback
like
i i do believe russell got to a point
last year i've said this on nfl live
many times
russell sits there and goes i gotta
score 35 a game
i'm not just trying to play good i have
to play
to win and unless you have the
the complimentary aspect of the football
team
that philosophy on offense doesn't mean
it's going to equal win
that's the real kind of reaching point
or whatever that those
those two have to kind of get to a an
agreement on
a few more minutes of smart football
talk with dan rolofsky nfl live
get up nfl and college football analyst
from the worldwide leader in sports
um perfect guy also to ask about uh
stafford in los angeles knowing stafford
knowing what he can do knowing the rams
knowing mcvay
knowing what they think he can do how is
this marriage going to work
do you think oh fantastic i put them as
the third team to be in the nfc and
they're still question marks with the
with the the bucks and the packers who
are going to be one two
with some of their free agents um i'll
say this the style of offense that
first the multitudes of play action pass
the hard ball which is like that quick
fake
downhill and trying to get like the 12
15 yard chunk throws that you got to
throw into small windows
obviously perfect for matthew stafford's
skill set both ball handling and arm
strength wise
and then the big ball play action where
you're going a little bit more drawn out
fake and you're trying to really get
those big throws down the field that's
what that offense missed last year
his skill set his athleticism his strong
arm is going to be allowed to do that
they've got to add one more speed piece
on the outside i do believe that a wide
receiver to kind of take off
the top of that cover so it's going to
help their play-action game
uh number two he's going to increase
their drop back game sometimes the play
actually passed this doesn't work
sometimes the defenses are going to
commit to stopping that rather than the
run or what not
and so you got to be able to play play
action or drop back football and that's
not something that jared did well that
matthew stafford can so sean mcveigh's
got a a comfort level knowing all right
this guy can cut a part of defense
because he's just so good so smart
scenes so much and then the last thing
is he can throw guys open better than
jared
you know because when you have talent
vision you see colors you see windows
you can make those sidearm throws a
little bit more um that's gonna help um
and so it's a fantastic scheme fit style
of play fit
i'd say this matthew stafford has had a
top ten defense in his nfl career
one time he went 11-5 that year
he's never had a top 10 run game ever
the rams averaged 136 yards
per game on the ground last year matthew
stafford's
best season is like 89 or something like
that
or that's what he averaged last year his
best season's like 101 so
he's never had a top 10 defense in a top
10 run game
ever never been in this environment i
think for those two reasons
we'll we will see the best version we've
ever seen of matthew stafford with the
rams
and dan orlowski i guess before i let
you go um you know this isn't just for
me because i'm
uh a jet fan but the jets do
have a lot um to say
about the next couple of months and how
that
domino effect can affect everybody if
they keep darnold that means they might
trade the second
overall pick if they use the second
overall pick
on uh a quarterback that makes darnold
available for somebody else or the
ultimate motherload if they somehow
convince the texans to realize what the
rest of the free world is currently
realizing
um that they wind up with watson what do
you think the jets wind up doing over
the next
seven weeks that affects the rest of the
nfl dan orlando well as i sit here now
march 2nd i think they'll keep sam
darnold and trade the second pick
um i i think what they'll do is keep sam
donald and make everyone think that
they're absolutely head over heels in
love with zach wilson to force
a team to go get him candidly i have not
studied zack wilson
every snap of zach wilson i've seen a
couple games i'm on fields right now
getting to zach wilson fourth in the
list
so i'm intrigued by him i'm intrigued by
fields as well
i think they both have some really
interesting traits but i just say this
be super cautious on packing uh passing
up on a really talented player
because he had an absolute disaster
around him
uh he's cut from the right stuff sam
darnold he's made from the right
mentality
he's still incredibly talented and young
and i just
believe that the jets coaching staff the
timing of when they went to new york
they did not study those young kids yet
so them
choosing the jets over all those other
options
i think tells us what the coaching staff
believes of sam darnold
as of right now i think they'll keep
them so the darnold that we
we evaluated in usc and could possibly
see
still exists based on the the dumpster
fire that frequently surrounded him over
the first three years of his career you
think that fits the shanahan system
that's being brought over
by robert saul unquestionably that is
the
perfect system percent on the it's a
perfect system for a lot of quarterbacks
it's a very
friendly system um but i think it's a
really really good fit i always say this
don't
we should never say fit can the player
excel and i think sam darnold can excel
in that offense
dan thanks for the time look for my call
please keep uh keep looking
brother right back at you that's dan
orlowski hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here